Hey I'm Kennedy for Reason TV,
I got kids,
during the holidays I like to sit down with
my girls
and watch some family friendly freedom focused
films
about Christmas cheer.
And when I'm chuggin' my 100 proof gluten-free
eggnog
I want to make sure my girls are mainlining
liberty.
So, with the help of Reason film critic and
my good friend Kurt Loder,
we put together a list of classic holiday
movies to avoid and to imbibe
all to help you enjoy a responsible Libertarian
Christmas.
First up, the cinematic lumps of coal.
A Charlie Brown Christmas,
the titular blockhead is offended by the commercialization of Christmas
which is a neat trick to pull off during a
Christmas special
sponsored by Dolly Madison snack cakes.
'I don't care.'
Poor little Charlie Brown is clearly an enemy
of capitalism,
who probably grows up to join occupy hell.
'Everything I touch gets ruined.'
A Christmas Memory propagates the un-Libertarian
idea
that getting blind drunk during the holidays
is somehow wrong.
'Are you out of your mind?'
Love Actually propagates the un-Libertarian
idea that getting blind drunk
and watching porn during the holidays is somehow
wrong-
'Rubbish'
White Christmas, two showbiz sisters, played
by Vera-Ellen
and George Clooney's aunt Rosemary,
destroy an expensive rug that is the private
property of their landlord.
Instead of making the ethically necessary
restitution, they run out on this obligation.
This is offensive, and not just for Libertarians.
Miracle on 34th Street, actor Kris Kringle
is dispatched to the nervous hospital
for insisting that he's really Santa Claus,
the post office saves the day, 'nuff said.
'You're making a mistake.'
FedEx woulda sprung him overnight.
Now to be fair there was some debate about
this movie in the Reason office,
with Mike Riggs quick to point out
it's one of his favorite pro-Libertarian Christmas movies
because it exposes government corruption
and showcases the horrors of involuntary commitment.
Now here are the good Libertarian Christmas
movies, we need this, right?
My favorite is Rudolph the Red-Nosed Reindeer.
Oh Rudolph!
Rudolph's distinguishing characteristic is
universally seen as a deformity
and he's outcast from the reindeer games and
the herd.
Yet, through self examination and reinvention,
he turns his perceived impairment into an asset
and becomes the most popular reindeer of all
time.
In the process he saves his gal and his parents
and befriends precious metal loving prospector
Yukon Cornelius.
'I'm off to get my life sustaining supplies,
cornmeal and gunpowder and ham hocks and guitar
strings.'
Then there's the brief moment in the sentimental
holiday standard It's A Wonderful Life,
when bankster George Bailey travels to Pottersville,
the place his home town of Bedford Falls would
have become if he'd never been born.
Now we only see Pottersville for a few moments,
but it looks to be a city comprised solely
of whore houses and gin mills,
which is pretty awesome.
'Hee-haw and merry Christmas.'
My other holiday favorite, which is not itself
a Christmas movie
but has become one over the years by default,
is The Sound of Music which is endlessly lovable.
How could you not adore a plucky, anti-authoritarian
nun,
who's a thorn in the side of the church and
the loins of the tyrannical naval captain
whom she wins over despite making lederhosen
out of green drapes.
That she also takes down the entire Nazi regime,
yeah just gravy really.
Now which other movies deserve to make it
on our list?
Anti-Libertarian holiday movies have no place in a
freedom friendly family room,
always looking out for you.
For Reason TV, I'm Kennedy.